what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so with the whole batch age story
with like Wolverine Hulk basically
coming to an end relatively soon I
figured what we do is go ahead and jump
into this and we would cover the kind of
pre loot to this now the way this works
it is designed to cross over to
different stories Weapon X and it's
designed to cross over into totally also
Hulk and so we'll actually end up seeing
like a whole tout Wolverine or at least
that seems to be the case and for people
who have been around Marvel Comics for a
while the main villain at the end of all
this uh well actually kind of blow your
mind it'll be a little crazy but what we
end up doing here is we actually
initially pick up with old man Logan now
again this is kind of a cool thing
because with regards to this it really
just kind of picks up an old man loaded
in the solace of his own life now there
are a couple of assumptions we end up
having to make here the first is that
this basically seems to be in a place
where either people are for the most
part recognizing what's going on with
the idea that the old man Logan is not
the original Wolverine and at the very
least it also seems to follow up after
the events of the old man Logan stories
that we've done so far
whereby he basically just kind of walks
away from his past in the wasteland and
starts focusing on the here and now the
idea here is that it's just he's kind of
out doing his own thing but the fact
remains that in the middle of all this
he's actually met by a couple of hikers
who reveal themselves to basically be
robots designed for the purpose of
assassinating him now there are a couple
of things here that are actually pretty
big the first is that they're able to
get past Wolverines enhanced senses and
so of course we're like sight and sound
and taste and so on and so forth don't
really matter this sense of smell does
when it comes to old man Logan because
of the fact that he's been around for so
long there are certain cues that he
picks up that something's just not right
and when coming across various
individuals who don't have a sense
because there's cyborg the initial
thought is okay like there ought to kill
me or somebody's going on but at the
very least like like an animal kind of
out there and potentially hearing a
sound they don't recognize they
immediately kind of perk up and will
range the exact same way he would
normally react by simply just being like
what in the world is going on now of
course because of the fact that he picks
up a scent what it means is that these
robots have been designed for the
purpose of tricking individuals like
Wolverine who have enhanced senses and
who have enhanced durability now
something else to focus on here is the
idea of Lady Deathstrike the last we saw
her it was basically border town
giant skirmished that old man Logan had
been involved in when he was getting his
stories told by writer Jeff Lemire in
his solo series but the two of them had
engaged in a conflict of sorts and then
Lady Deathstrike had sort of gone on her
own and done her own thing of course I
believe we have Weapon X issue number
zero down in our channel if we do I will
have it the playlist but the long and
short of it is that for those of you
guys who aren't who aren't really
keeping up Lady Deathstrike is part
robot in part human making her a cyborg
but the overall idea is that she has
like an enhanced healing factor
adamantium claws different things like
that she has in a lot of ways the same
thing that will rain does now of course
this is all really rooted in her past in
the sense that she harbors a personal
grudge against against Wolverine which
is the reason for why she became the
person she is anyway but what we also
end up finding out here is that there
are a group of individuals who are
basically serving the purpose of trying
to track down people like Wolverine
specifically warpath and Domino as well
as Sabretooth so that's why it's kind of
a big deal because it means there's an
organized attempt to track them down now
what this does is it leads to old man
Logan seeking out Sabretooth and
Sabretooth is a character that we
haven't really talked about too much
here on my channel the idea here is that
his character is kind of waxed and waned
and experienced his own changes over
years and he's really one of the more
popular characters of The Wolverine
mythos overall Sabretooth had basically
been decapitated by the original
Wolverine but what ended up happening is
that writer Jeph Loeb was actually
making that story at the time and then
in turn brought him back later on down
the line now Sabretooth has historically
again always been one of like Wolverines
most notable villains if not his arch
nemesis and so the result of this is
that with Sabretooth having returned he
was still very much a bad guy and this
continued on until the axis storyline
when Marvel went through and took the
most popular characters and some of the
most popular villains and basically
inverted them temporarily now that
lasted for the length of axis and that's
where the whole character of Klaw comes
from the incredible hopes Hulk which we
will do a video on that but the idea
here is that during the axis event
Sabretooth had basically childen himself
by way of by way of Tony Stark so that
when he was inverted to become a good
guy and then things went back he stayed
a good guy now what this did is it
allowed Marvel to go forward and
basically revamp the entirety of
Sabretooth by having him try to go
through and make himself basically a
hero try to redeem himself for the past
things that he had done
the problem with this was that in a lot
of ways it was really just wasted and
that was one of the most disappointing
things he joined the Avengers unity
squad for a little while he was part of
Magneto's x-men when Marvel was trying
to destroy the x-men trying to character
assassinate the x-men it was really kind
of one of those weird scenarios but this
actually gives us a pretty cool
situation because again with old man
Logan showing up on the doorstep of
Sabretooth is actually not what it seems
with Sabretooth of course being a little
hostile here Logan basically says look
there's a couple of individuals who were
disguised as cyborgs that track me down
and tried to kill me
Sabretooth reveals he was in the exact
same boat but where same retreats wants
to walk away again doesn't really want
to be involved in this whole situation
he's really kind of forced into it when
Logan says look they probably picked up
my scent and they're on their way here
which is kind of cool because basically
now the hosts a retreat has to sort of
jump into the conflict with old man
Logan himself but this actually takes up
with James proud star also known as
warpath now the funny thing about this
is a James Brown star is not the first
person to ever use the moniker warpath
in fact John proudest star was the first
one to use it but he died two issues in
and so it didn't really matter that that
he was warpath to one point in time
James Krause star is really the most
popular version because he's been been
Warcraft for so long but I don't really
know why he's in this story because
historically speaking James proud star
never had a healing factor before but he
has one now the only thing that I can
think of is that you know where James
Krause star having been brought into
uncanny x-force he was basically just
kind of considered to be someone who
fought alongside the original Wolverine
had to be hence of Cyclops
but with Warcraft being on that team it
creates some measure of familiarity I
guess again I'm not really sure why it
is that that he's been rolled into this
but the fact remains he basically has a
healing factor now so again much like
old man Logan's encounter with these
cyborgs we get a little more about this
particular organization that's operating
in this kind of bio refinery and a
Weapon X satellite and what that means
is again you know kind of getting into a
little bit of history here the Weapon X
project the main facility they had in
Canada was not the only one they had the
weapon X facility had different
facilities across the world and across
the country the idea was that despite it
being a joint venture between the CIA
and Canada's Department K at the end of
the day it was still designed just
create super soldiers and it's him to
basically mimic Captain America and so
the result is that this is just one of
those many satellites that sort of the
just out there the question is who's
pulling the strings and why are they
there well of course with Sabretooth &
warpath and these guys facing off
against these different cyborgs for the
most part Sabretooth in old man Logan
are able to get past their guys for John
proud stars ultimately captured and so
the results of this is that it seems as
though those organizations basically
going through and just nabbing different
people here and there who have healing
factors and just kind of bringing them
together now from here we jump to Domino
and Domino is actually kind of a weird
situation in this particular story but
she's also got a pretty interesting
power the way the her ability works is
to effectively bend luck in her favor
and so it doesn't mean that she can like
manipulate reality or anything along
those lines it's simply just that like
if she's like oh man you know she's
walking around somewhere she's like I
could really use $100 because I can't
afford what it is that I need then
suddenly circumstances will unfold and
she'll suddenly have $100 now of course
this is usually done in Marvel Comics by
way of her being in conflicts and things
just kind of unfold in a way she
suddenly finds an opening in the middle
of a conflict or something along those
lines as she can make her escape but the
idea here is that she was actually part
I think she originally appeared an
x-force issue number 8 and I want to say
that she was either a backup feature or
she was part way kind of her origin sort
of introduced into the story but the
idea here is that she was biologically
engineered was broken out kind of
stumbled her way across the world and
eventually joined a six pack or maybe
was wild pack I don't remember what it
was called at the time but it was
basically cables team it was more or
less than New Mutants before they became
x-force and ultimately she joined his
roster the two of them fell in love for
a while
for the most part she played a
background role she was never really
that significant and Marvel Comics her
being brought in here this ultimately
results in a couple of these guys a
couple of these robots going after her
now of course Nina does not have a
healing factor and even the people who
are watching this event unfold comment
on that and the question that's being
asked here is if warpath has a healing
factor and you know if if the Incredible
Hulk has a healing factor and Wolverine
and Sabretooth both have healing factors
why are they going after Domino and
again it's just because of the fact that
she can bend luck in her favor and so
what this seems to be doing at least
what seems to be going on is there's
this sort of perfect amalgamation
whereby the person who is created here
will ultimately result in someone that
has a healing factor that will have the
enhanced strength of the Incredible Hulk
adamantium component and we'll also be
able to bend Lex to their
they burn so there'll be quite a
formidable force to be reckoned with and
so again it's kind of a cool idea but of
course this whole scenario basically
unfolds under the under the watchful eye
of some hidden man some hidden figure
but jumping to two totally awesome Hulk
to Amadeus Cho but this particular a bit
of a story Amadeus Cho again is really
kind of reckless and that was really the
nature of his character the way he was
designed to be done when he was maybe
Incredible Hulk is he doesn't have the
forethought he doesn't have the
wherewithal doesn't have the experience
he hawks out he just kind of jumps
headstrong into a situation he lets his
abilities get the better of him and the
result if they doesn't really think to
the future which is kind of ironic for a
guy who's effectively the eighth
smartest man and the world and so again
it's kind of an interesting scenario
here because facing off against these
robots they kind of appear out of
nowhere in the midst of what he believes
to be going through and basically
rescuing you know a shuttle that's kind
of gone arrived this also goes into the
idea of these robots having a
self-destruct mechanism this group
basically sending these robots in for
the purpose of capturing people with
abilities and then in turn if the robots
fail having them self-destruct so nobody
can trace where they came from or who
they are with Domino having been rescued
by the efforts of Sabretooth and by the
efforts of old man Logan this ultimately
results in her teaming up alongside the
tube and then finding Amadeus Cho now
force Amadeus Cho rescuing them as well
and everybody's sort of meeting up again
the reckless nature of his character
comes into play when one he taunts
Sabretooth a little bit here and there
where he shows up with half of one of
these robots but not being able to trace
its particular location or at least not
seemingly being able to and then
ultimately it being revealed that in his
humorous and the fact that he got
carried away that his blood was left out
there and that some of these guys were
able to basically grab this sample of
his blood and then whisk it away back to
their location and so again this all
kind of comes full circle when they're
ultimately able to trace now that this
came from a Weapon X facility of sorts
now this basically is an old Roxxon oil
rig and it's kind of a funny thing
because with rocks on oil they're one of
like these major perforations that exist
in Marvel Comics that you don't really
hear about that often if you're new here
Roxxon has really been like a major
focal point in the Mighty Thor line of
stories but outside of that you don't
really see them that often but they're
basically one of these major oil tycoons
where the oil aspect is really a front
for them to engage in all different
manner of like corruption whether it's
bribing political officials having
people assassinated all different kinds
of things whether
basically three main scientists that are
helping to run this show that are going
through and that are basically just kind
of serving the purpose of capturing
these people now the other half of this
is that because this is an oil facility
the world can't know what's going on
this leads to oh man Logan and Domino
and Amadeus charile and Sabretooth you
know breaking into the facility and
trying to destroy it as best they can
and then ultimately rescuing Lady
Deathstrike the problem with all this is
that what they've attacked is not
actually the home base of where that's
what the next project is operating out
of or at least this newest iteration of
the web the next project we're
separating out of and so the result is
that the once they realize what's going
on their intention is to basically fly
out track down these guys now the other
half of this is that they have basically
been able to synthesize what it is that
makes the Incredible Hulk the Incredible
Hulk
this in addition is basically being tied
to these other mutants are the DNA of
these other mutants to create this sort
of super mutant and the result is that
we end up finding out the person behind
all this is Reverend William Stryker now
this is a huge revelation in this story
and that's one of the reasons why I kind
of you know I've been kind of beating
around the bush in terms of everything
that's going on when it comes to
Reverend Stryker he is a guy who
basically believes it's his mission from
God to kill mutants and he's probably
one of the most interesting villains in
the history of Marvel Comics originally
his character debuted a story called God
loves man kills and he was writer Chris
Claremont real first foray into dealing
with a story that focuses on like
prejudice and different things like that
for example there's an instance in that
story where Kitty Pryde is talking to
storm about the issue of racism and
where somebody talks about basically
insults Kitty Pryde because she's a
mutant Kitty Pryde a storm how would you
respond if somebody referred to you is
like the n-word so throwing things like
that in there were pretty huge at the
time I mean they were pretty good it was
a really controversial story but they
were pretty huge at the time because it
went towards bolstering the humanity of
the x-men now really with William
Stryker as time progressed he was
significant to a degree but he really
fell into the background I mean he was
not nearly as relevant like you know as
he was when he first popped up and it
went on that way for probably a decade
or so maybe a couple decades his return
so to speak you know kind of like his
stepping back into the limelight
came during the events of Messiah
Complex but the idea of Messiah Complex
was that it dealt with a concept of Hope
Summers
this little
girl who was born the first mutant born
after the Scarlet Witch had stripped the
mutant population there stood 98% of
them of their powers and so it was a
huge deal when she first popped out of
course the x-men realized what was going
on they were sent to find her but so
were a host of other people William
Stryker was one of those who responded
and William Stryker looked at the events
of Scarlet Witch and said God made it
this way God wants the mutants to be
gone and so we are going to continue his
work by trying to kill off what's left
of the 198 mutants and then when Hope
Summers popped up we ended up finding
out that William strikers forces of the
purifiers got to Alaska first and just
obliterated the village but before they
could find and kill kill hope summers
cable popped up and whisked her away and
so again that was really kind of like
his return and he just sort of
disappeared again for a little while I
mean he had his own little stories going
on but after the events of Messiah
Complex and the sigh of war and all that
kind of good stuff going to like the
heroic age and so on and so forth but
him returning here means that this batch
age which we combined DNA of Sabretooth
and Lady Deathstrike and Domino and
warpath and the Incredible Hulk
is going to serve the purpose of
tracking down and eliminating every
mutant that it comes across and that's
actually pretty significant and what
this story does is it throws into show
of relief the nature of wolf rain the
reason why it is that people with
healing factors are some of the most
powerful mutants when it comes to a
healing factor a person can basically
recover from virtually anything shy of
Deadpool Wolverines healing factor is
probably one of the best in the world
and so combining his abilities alongside
domino's ability to then luck in her
favor and the enhanced strength of the
Incredible Hulk means that whatever this
monster is will take its direction from
William Stryker
it'll be tasked with killing every
mutant it can come across and so this
thing is going to have a healing factor
that's going to have virtually unlimited
strength any mutant that tries to face
off against it shy of those that can
warp reality or totally obliterate this
thing in its entirety are going to fall
so again this sets the stage for a
pretty significant event also keep in
mind that while mutants are starting to
pop up to a degree they're nowhere near
as large a number as they were before
the events of house events and so it
would not be a difficult task for
whatever this creature is to go through
and just start killing off mutants
everywhere and eliminate the entirety of
the mutant population from the face of
the earth but with that being said guys
we're going to go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you
new here to comment explain make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the Rob pork you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later peace
[Music]